[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halbweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert König
für den Sport gerne guten Abend und das
sind die Nachrichten Themen von heute
Explosionen Istanbul mindestens sechs
Menschen sterben in einer beliebten
Einkaufsstraße
Kanzler auf Werbetour in Vietnam will
Olaf Scholz neben der wirtschaftlichen
auch die politische Zusammenarbeit
stärken
und Triumph der US-Demokraten der Sieg
im Bundesstaat Nevada sichert der Partei
von Präsident beiden die Mehrheit im
Senat
[Musik]
Schock in Istanbul bei einer
Bombenexplosion sind mindestens sechs
Menschen ums Leben gekommen mehr als 50
wurden verletzt der türkische Präsident
Erdogan spricht von einem hinterhältigen
Anschlag die explosione eignete sich am
Nachmittag im Zentrum der
Millionenmetropole in der auch bei
Touristen beliebten Fußgängerzone ist
egal waren viele Menschen unterwegs aus
Istanbul berichtet Lück valpott
Chaos und Entsetzen kurz nach 16 Uhr
heute auf der istikal einer der
bekanntesten Einkaufsstraßen im Zentrum
Istanbuls nach einer heftigen Explosion
regelten Sicherheitskräfte das Areal ab
Anlieger wurden in Sicherheit gebracht
es gab zahlreiche Verletzte
nähere Angaben zum Geschehen gab es aber
zunächst nicht die Behörden verhängten
eine Nachrichtensperre um weitere Panik
zu vermeiden im Netz kursierten da schon
Videos über den mutmaßlichen Anschlag es
wird spekuliert dass eine Paketbombe
gezündet wurde die an einer Bank
abgestellt war
es gab einen ungeheuren Knall schwarzer
Rauch dann rannten alle in Panik davon
ich habe drei Leute auf dem Boden liegen
sehen
Präsident Erdogan auf dem Weg zum
G20-Gipfel in Bali sprach von einem
hinterhältigen Anschlag
wir können noch nicht mit Sicherheit
sagen dass das ein Terroranschlag war
aber erst der Ermittlungen weisen
deutlichen diese Richtung gucke
die Einkaufsstraße eine Fußgängerzone im
Zentrum Istanbuls unweit des
taksimplatzes ist vor allem bei
Touristen ein beliebtes Ziel vor sechs
Jahren hatte sich hier ein
Selbstmordattentäter in die Luft
gesprengt und fünf Menschen getötet der
Anschlag wurde damals der Terrorgruppe
islamischer Staat zugeschrieben zu der
Explosion heute hat sich bislang niemand
bekannt
die Abhängigkeit von China verringern
das ist ein Ziel der viertägigen
Asienreise von Bundeskanzler Scholz los
ging es heute in Vietnam das
kommunistisch geführte Land mit seinen
fast 100 Millionen Einwohnern ist schon
jetzt Deutschlands wichtigster
Handelspartner in Südostasien schakota
la banaji berichtet für einen Moment
scheint es als er das kein Arbeitsbesuch
Herr neues ausgemalle am Sonntag
Wohlstand Trubel und mittendrin der
Bundeskanzler
dass Sie ihn hier treffen verdanken sie
der Krise in der Energieversorgung im
Welthandel und im Gleichgewicht der
Weltmächte Vietnam ist eines der Länder
die Deutschland in Zeiten von Pandemie
und Ukraine Krieg noch mehr braucht als
Konsequenz müssen wir unsere
Absatzmärkte unsere Lieferketten unsere
Rohstoffquellen und unsere
Produktionsstandorte
erweitern damit wir nicht von einzelnen
Staaten und Lieferanten abhängig sind da
spielt die Zusammenarbeit mit Vietnam
eine ganz ganz zentrale Rolle bisher ist
Vietnam vor allem Wirtschaftspartner nun
soll das Land auch politische
Verbündeter werden in Ringen mit
Großmächten wie China und Russland
[Musik]
vereinbaren Partnerschaften um globale
Probleme zu lösen für Frieden
Kooperation Solidarität und Sicherheit
in der Welt Heere Ziele die dem
Schwellenland Vietnam mehr Gewicht
verleihen im Poker mit den großen
Vietnam gehört zu den schwierigeren
Partnern in Scholz Plänen für neue
Handels- und sicherheitsbeziehungen der
kommunistische ein Parteienstaat ist eng
mit China verbunden und steht in der
Kritik für die harte Unterdrückung der
Opposition im eigenen Land auch was die
Ukraine betrifft stehen Stolz und seine
Gastgeber nicht auf einer Seite bisher
hat Vietnam den Angriffskrieg Russlands
nicht verurteilt
das Werben um neue Netzwerke in Asien
hat gerade erst begonnen morgen reist
Scholz weiter nach Singapur
[Musik]
ein ungewöhnlich scharfer Ton herrscht
derzeit zwischen Deutschland und der
iranischen Regierung gestern hatte
karlskanzler Scholz ihr vorgeworfen auf
die eigene Bevölkerung zu schießen heute
die Antwort aus Teheran Scholz Worte
sein provozierend und wenig diplomatisch
Deutschland missbrauche Menschenrechte
für politische Spielchen
vier Tage nach den Kongresswahlen in den
USA steht fest die Demokraten von
Präsident beiden behalten ihre Mehrheit
im Senat mit dem Sieg in Nevada stellen
Sie künftig mindestens 50 Senatoren die
Republikaner haben derzeit 49 ein Sitz
ist noch nicht vergeben bei einem Pad
entscheidet die Stimme der
demokratischen Vizepräsidentin camella
Harris sie ist senatspräsidentin aus
Washington sonnewald
mit dem Sieg der Senatorin Katherine
Cortes masto im US-Bundesstaat Nevada
haben die Demokraten unerwartet ihre
Mehrheit im Senat verteidigt für
Präsident beiden zur Zeit in Asien ist
dieser Sieg besonders bemerkenswert denn
bei den mitturms zur Hälfte der Amtszeit
werden Amtsinhaber oft mit Stimmverlust
abgestraft
ich bin ein unverbesserlicher Optimist
das Ergebnis überrascht mich nicht ich
fühle mich gut und ich freue mich auf
die nächsten paar Jahre
dass die Demokraten weiterhin die
Kontrolle über den Senat halten stärkt
die Partei so können die Republikaner
keine Gesetze die beiden Agenda
widersprechen durch den Kongress bringen
etwa zur Abtreibung oder zum Klimaschutz
dass die Demokraten es geschafft haben
die Kontrolle im Senat zu verteidigen
kann als riesiger Triumph gewertet
werden denn Präsident beiden
Umfragewerte sind im Keller deshalb
hatten eigentlich die Republikaner hier
mit einem erdrischartigen Sieg gerechnet
dass die von Trump unterstützten
Kandidaten bei den Wahlen einen solchen
Dämpfer erhalten haben sorgt nun
parteiintern für Kritik
Kandidaten die die Wahlen von 2020
anzweifelten und Verschwörungstheorien
verbreiteten wurden fast allesamt
zurückgewiesen das ist im Grunde die
dritte Wahl in Folge die Trump uns
vermasselt hat ich sage es ist wie beim
Baseball dreimal nicht getroffen und du
bist raus
Ex-Präsident Trump hat für Dienstag aus
seinem Domizil in Florida eine sehr
große Mitteilung angekündigt sollte er
wie spekuliert seine Kandidatur für 2024
bekannt geben kann er wohl nicht mehr
mit einem großen Rückhalt der
Republikaner rechnen
hierzulande stecken seit Wochen die
Tarifverhandlungen in der Metall- und
Elektroindustrie fest deshalb will die
Gewerkschaft ab morgen mit zusätzlichen
warnstreiksdruck machen und zwar in
Rheinland-Pfalz Hessen und Thüringen
ihre Forderungen nach 8% mehr Lohn
nennen die Arbeitgeber außer der Welt
haben aber aus Sicht der Gewerkschaft
selbst noch kein Substanzielles Angebot
vorgelegt
nach dem Abzug aus herson hat Russland
angekündigt die ukrainische Stadt
novakarovka zu evakuieren angeblich aus
Sorge dass der Staudamm dort bombardiert
und die Stadt überflutet werden könnte
in Person feiern die Bewohner weiter die
Befreiung ihrer Stadt ukrainische
polizeigeheimdienste und die
Bezirksverwaltung haben ihre Arbeit
wieder aufgenommen
der Krieg in der Ukraine prägte auch den
Volkstrauertag heute an dem erinnert
Deutschland an die Opfer von Krieg und
Gewaltherrschaft Bundespräsident
Steinmeier legte in der Gedenkstätte
neue Wache in Berlin einen Kranz nieder
anschließend Sprache im Bundestag als
Gastredner würdigte der lettische
Präsident Lewitz Deutschlands
schonungslose Aufarbeitung der eigenen
Geschichte
und jetzt sind wir beim Sport in München
kam heute die Fans von American Football
voll auf ihre Kosten haben sie bekamen
einige Touchdowns zu sehen mit 21 zu 16
gewinnen die Tampa Bay bakaneers gegen
die Seattle Seahawks das erste NFL Spiel
auf deutschem Boden
großartige Stimmung schon Stunden vor
der NFL Premiere in Deutschland und man
bekommt den Eindruck das ganz München
ins Stadion drängt um dabei zu sein auch
die Bayern-Profis Thomas Müller und
Serge gnabry warten geduldig auf den
Superstar der Tampa Bay Backen Niers
pünktlich um 15 Uhr ist Tom Brady bereit
im zweiten Viertel setzt sich der
45-Jährige in Szene ein Pass auf Julio
Jones Touchdown und die Führung im
letzten Abschnitt passt wieder Tom Brady
auf Chris Goodwin Touchdown am Ende
gewinnen die Baker Niers mit 21 zu 16
gegen die Seahawks bei der NFL Premiere
in Deutschland
der Moderne 5 Kampf wird sich nach einem
Beschluss des Weltverbandes nach den
Olympischen Spielen 2024 von der
Disziplin Springreiten verabschieden
spätestens nach dem Skandal um den
Umgang der deutschen Annika schleu mit
ihrem zugelosten Pferd im Vorjahr in
Tokio war die Entscheidung überfällig
die neue Disziplin auf dem
Hindernisparcour wird schon im kommenden
Jahr zumindest bei nationalen
Meisterschaften das Reiten ersetzen
das vorletzte Fußball-Bundesliga Spiel
2022 endet unentschieden 1 zu 1 zwischen
Mainz 05 und Eintracht Frankfurt durch
Treffer von Burkhardt und Kolo moani
und dritter starker Auftritt Dritter
Sieg die Eishockey Nationalmannschaft
der Männer gewinnt den Deutschlandcup
mit einem hoch verdienten 3:0 gegen den
Olympia 3 Slowakei
in Krefeld bezwingt ein junger aber sehr
abgeklärter Gastgeber in den weißen
Trikots ohne seine Stammkräfte die
Slowakei das 1:0 durch Wohlgemuth in
einem Spiel mit vielen Höhepunkten
Deutschland löst seine unterzahlen
Spiele glänzend mit Paraden von
Pankowski und behält den Überzahl die
Übersicht nach Eders 2:0 der Endstand
von Fleischer zum 3:0 zum 9 mal gewinnt
Deutschland das Turnier eine
erfolgreiche Prüfung für die kommende WM
und das war es vom Sport Dankeschön
bitteschön die neue Woche startet morgen
zumindest für einige sonnig nördlich des
Mains und im Südosten gibt es viel Sonne
im Südwesten sind die Wolken meist dicht
und es kann etwas regnen die Temperatur
steigt auf Werte von 9 bis 15 Grad
Marietta Slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal wir sagen
tschüss wünschen Ihnen einen guten Start
in die neue Woche und blicken jetzt
gespannt auf Theo Call und Berlin direkt